le 78 chronique de l'environnement avec
Valérie oribo bonsoir Valérie bonsoir
quel sera le thème de ce soir et bien ce
soir WF nous partons à la découverte des
terres agricoles de saquentin en Yveline
et du plateau de saclet avec
l'association Terre et cité avec nous en
plateau pour en parler et découvrir les
liens entre les sols et les exploitation
Dorian SPAC bonsoir et Florence godino
donc samedi dernier devait avoir lieu
une randonnée qui devait durer 3 heur
elle a été annulée pour cause d'
tempérie et de
neige en quoi comment s'articulent ces
ces randonnées quel est leur but alors
ces randonnées existent déjà depuis
c'est la 4e depuis que TER cité a a
décidé de faire découvrir le territoire
à tous les acteurs du plateau et donc
elles ont pour objectif premier de faire
découvrir le territoire les les
productions agricoles et tout ce qui
tout ce qui peut exister en terme de
biodiversité euh sur le plateau et sur
lesall RN au cours de ces randonnées
donc rencontre les producteurs locaux
déguste les produits tout à fait tout à
fait alors donc c'est ce sont des
parcours dans lequel on on on on a on
met en en en
évidence les producteurs du plateau donc
le long du parcours nous avons des
intervenants
soit sur la biodiversité mais vous avez
aussi la possibilité de visiter des
fermes des producteurs qui ouvrent leurs
fermes pour pouvoir expliquer leur
production leur leur métier tout
simplement d'accord alors quels sont C
justement ces cette biodiversité quelle
est cette biodiversité qui existe
notamment dans la vallée de Chevreuse
sur le plateau de Sacy alors vous avez
plusieurs formes de biodiversité puisque
vous avez plusieurs types d'écosystèmes
vous avez donc ce qu'on peut appeler la
biodiversité domestique avec
l'agriculture vous avez des forêts vous
avez des zones humides et vous avez donc
qui sont plus ou moins dans les vallées
et vous avez ces connexions qui existent
entre les écosystème et qui qui nous
procure non seulement une une fertilité
au niveau des sols une une protection au
niveau de la nappe fréatique enfin vous
avez des espaces ouverts qui sont tout à
fait préservés et protégés sur ce
plateau et les gens sont friants donc de
ces informations de cette connaissance
tout à fait tout à fait il souhait être
averti et avoir la possibilité de
découvrir avec des acteurs du plateau
enfin tout du moins locaux qui sont
susceptibles de répondre à leur à leurs
interrogations et et avoir dans C de ce
fait une des informations qui sont au
plus local possible il y a un côté
militant aussi dans votre association de
défense justement de de ces terre face à
l'urbanisme face face aux
villes c'est un peu le but de de de
l'association qui s'est développé he il
y a d'autres actions mais oui en fait
l'association effectivement c'est c'est
est né de
cette je dirais d'une certaine réaction
à une certaine peut-être une certaine
vision de la ville h
et en 2006 les l'État avait proposé une
ville nouvelle sur le plateau de saclet
de de 150000 logements et cetera donc
des choses qui sont quand même très
conséquente on en est assez loin
aujourd'hui euh tercité est né en 2000
donc même au auparavant de ça mais ça
fait longtemps qu'il y a des projets
d'urbanisation sur le plateau de saclé
l'ambition de teréréité c'est pas d'être
une association militante contre tout
projet d'urbanisation et cetera c'est
vraiment d'arriver à construire avec
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux un projet
qui permet de valoriser les espaces
agricoles les espaces ouverts du du
territoire on compte parmi les membres
de l'Association des personnes qui sont
pas de par leur activité euh de fait des
défenseurs fervants forcément des terres
agricooles mais qui on on a par exemple
une personne qui est qui a une position
de direction synchro TR soleil donc un
gros établissement de recherche un gros
établissement industriel mais c'est des
personnes qui se rendent compte que cet
environnement apporte aussi justement à
la dimension urbaine du plateau quelque
chose de très intéressant quelque chose
qui fait que ce
territoire se différencie de du reste de
l'île-de-fance
et la fonction de biodiversité dont
parlait Florence est importante enfin le
plateau de Sacla c'est une grande
pénétrante agricole AUAU auveau RG c'est
ai une grande effectivement TER d'espace
naturel et et c'est quelque chose qui
qui qui contribue à l'attractivité au
dynamisme de ce territoire alors le
projet du Grand Paris notamment pose
question et et remet en question
justement cette cette réserve de de
terres agricoles il y a quand même une
évolution assez significative sur ce
pointl c'està-dire que le la loi du
Grand Paris du 3 juin 2010 et la
première loi qui prévoit une une grande
opération d'aménagement qui qui prévoit
en même temps que l'opération
d'aménagement la préservation d'une zone
de protection sanctuirisée donc la zone
de protection des espaces naturels
agricoles et forestier du plateau de
saclet bon 2 au moins 2300 hactares
d'après la loi on espère que ce sera un
petit peu plus mais voilà il a cette il
y a cette base là donc on sent qu'on est
déjà quand même a priori sur une
démarche qui est plus une démarche de
dire on va tout urbaniser c'estàdire que
d en partant du moment où on on part du
principe qu'on va urbaniser une partie
du plateau on pose en parallèle les
garanties pour s'assurer que le reste
puisse garder une fonctionnalité
agricole à long terme d'autant que ces
terres font partie des plus fertiles
d'île-de France hein on y cultive les
céréales principalement non seulement
d'Île de France mais même de France et
d'Europe euh on
a on a des des moyennes de production
sur le plateau de saclet qui sont de
mémoire de 10 à 15 quintau par hectare
en production de blé de 10 à 15 quintau
par hectare supérieur ce qu'on a en on
et lesesson même et elle-même 10 à 15
quinau supérieur à ce qu'on a au niveau
niveau de moyenne
nationale voilà on a très régulièrement
sur le plateau de saclet des parcelles
où on fait plus de 100 quinteau à
hectare c'est et en plus c'est des
terres qui sont extraordinairement
résistante à la sécheresse parce qu'en
fait on a une couche une couche d'argile
avec quelques mètres de Lim par-dessus
mais du coup la couche d'argile retient
l'eau et donc du coup pendant les les
grands épisodes de chchess qu'on a connu
récemment alors qu'au nord son on
perdait 50 à 75 % des récoltes dans
certains cas sur le plateau de sa on
fait quasiment les les mêmes rendements
sans avoir à iréger les terres donc on a
vraiment dans le
contexte quand même assez difficile
qu'on devrait avoir au niveau de des
questions environnementales dans les
années qui viennent on a des terres qui
sont assez exceptionneles même
franchement exceptionnel dans la manière
dont elle dont elle se comporte et qu'il
est essentiel de préserver il est
essentiel aussi de de ramener
l'agriculteur à la place qu'il occupait
autrefois c'est-à-dire de liens social
de de protection du du du
paysage oui de de le ramener à la place
qu'il occupa autre fois peut-être de lui
trouver une place aujourd'hui euh
surtout euh puisque voilà avec la la
mise en place de la PAC et cetera le le
producteur est souvent passé dans une
position justement juste de production
alors qu'en fait il a vraiment un rôle
de lien social fort à jouer au niveau du
territoire en faisant découvrir le
territoire en le faisant vivre au niveau
paysager et cetera et puis en vendant
ses produits en direct à la ferme et
cetera il est amené à mettre en contact
en fait beaucoup de gens au niveau d'un
territoire alors on va le voir à travers
un sujet tourné notamment avec Patrick
Jacques de d'xmud en novembre dernier ce
sont les les moulins de Brasseuil qui
eux aussi cultivent de la farine bio
c'est un tournant de plus en plus
prignant au sein de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui jadis àreville les moulins
de Brasseuil étaient à haut et si la
rivière est imuable les moulins eux ont
évolué mais dans cette profession
exercée de père en fils la tradition
demeure malgré la modernisation
précurseur de la filière bio depuis 1972
c'est le seul site des ivelines à
posséder un moulin à Meul en pierre et à
cylindre on revient vers le côté nature
qui a été un petit peu décrié un peu
chahuté dans les années précédentes et
qui a aujourd'hui prend son prend sa
vraie existence son son sa vraie valeur
en ayant des produits naturels des
produits tracés des produits de la
région ce en quoi nous on croit depuis
des années à aujourd'hui ben on est
content que ça se en île-defance on on
Rev VO cette cette force c'est une vraie
force des mou de brassil exemple
d'engrais et de produits chimiques les
farines bio conservent toutes leur
qualité nutritionnelle blé sègle épôtre
et petite épatre inlassablement les
farines sont écrasées broyé et renvoyé
d'un bout à l'autre des
conduits contrôle qualité vérification
suivi des dossiers le métier de meunier
aussi s'est adapté au temps
moderne je dirais que le métier il a un
petit peu évolué parce que en tant que
Responsable de Production avant c'est
essentiellement être beaucoup beaucoup
sur le terrain alors que ça l'est
toujours mais parallèlement il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de travail en amont
lié à la qualité au matériel à la
maintenance donc c'est beaucoup plus
complet je pense qu'avant c'était il y a
il y a de ça plusieurs années en arrière
c'était surtout beaucoup plus technique
le bio exige de la transparence et une
traçabilité les échanges avec les
laboratoires pour analyser les qualité
des produits son lesgion une exigence
qui engendre un chiffre d'affaires de
3450000 € en évolution malgré la crise
car la part du bio augmente d'année en
année une offure qui répond à une
demande croissante en 2011 les moulins
de Brasseuil ont produit 5258 tonnes de
farine
deux dernières dates à annoncer oui
alors de deux événements en fait la
première c'est propose une une sortie
découverte qui est en partie sur la
communauté d'agglomération de 5 an
yvelin le 27 avril prochain donc vous
trouverez des informations sur le site
de l'association et la seconde c'est
qu'on mène actuellement un cycle de
concertation pour proposer à tous les
acteurs du territoire qui souhaitent
réfléchir justement le devenir de ces
terres agricoes donc on va voir un
certain nombre d'événements grand public
au printemps et de même vous trouverez
les informations assez prochainement sur
le site sur le site de l'association si
ça vous intéresse de venir participer à
la réflexion sur le devenir des espaces
agricoles du plateau de sa avec des
événements festifs qui viennent
compléter ce citele de concertation
d'accorder àiter le site association
Térité merci à tous les deux Valérie
pour conclure ce rendez-vous
environnement de rendez-vous dans
l'agenda oui quel éconsommateur
êtes-vous ce sera la question posée par
la Maison de l'Environnement le samedi
26 janvier à 10h l'occasion de
rencontrer les acteurs du sel de
Rambouillet he ces associations qui
privilé qui privilégie pardon l'échange
de bien de savoir-faire et de service on
va faire un focus sur le sel d'ailleurs
dans un instant avec un reportage de la
rédaction et puis autre rendez-vous dans
l'agenda projection une projection à
suivre une projection d'un documentaire
de Coline cro solution locale pour un
désordre global l'occasion de répondre
en fait au au problèmes des désordres
écologiques qui nous préoccupent le film
sera diffusé le mardi 29 janvier à 20h30
à la Maison de Quartier Joseph Cosma de
guillancour suivi d'un débat merci
Valérie prochain rendez-vous
environnement dans le 78 la semaine
prochaine au mêmes horair et puis
également sur TVfil le magazine
équilibre équilibre consacré ce mois-ci
à
l'éconsommation le sel le système
d'échange local le sel c'est très utile
vous nous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui he sur les routes c'est
aussi un système d'échange les adhérents
de Guill en cour par exemple s'échange
toutes sortes de services il n'y a pas
de notion d'argent la seule monnaie
fictive existante s'appelle la
grenouille
bonsoir c'est dans son appartement que
l'alita adérante du à gu en cour depuis
3 ans reçoit Lisette inscrite elle
depuis 1 an et demi les deux adhérentes
ont l'habitude d'échanger des services
la spécialité de Lita les masses tu
préères auourdhu Jas comme
d'habit là j'ai cette fois-ci l'argon
qu'est-ce que tu veux l'AND
andeande h ça va sentir bon au sel de
guilloncour chacun possède des
l'inscription 75 points ici les euros
sont bannis et sont remplacés par des
grenouilles par exemple quelqu'un qui a
besoin qu'on qu'on vientne jardiner chez
lui puis on demande de l'aide on on met
une annonce et en fonction de la
personne qui dit oui j'accepte de vous
couper je sais pas de tailler la par
exemple pour 2h en échange me donner C
compes grenouilles si on est d'accord on
négocie le nombre de grenouilles si on
est d'accord on accepte à ce moment-là
la personne qui a un jardin qui qui a
qui avait besoin de cette aide donne ce
compte grenouille à l'autre personne les
adhérents du sel peuvent aussi échanger
en fonction de leur savoir-faire sans
amputer leur nombre de points Lisette a
gardé la fille de l'alita durant
plusieurs jours après l'école le massage
ne lui coûtera donc aucune grenouille ce
soir bah comme on vit dans une société
de consommation moi ce qui m'a vraiment
attiré dans dans un premier temps
c'était voilà tout est recyclé bah la
table qui est partie qui voulait partir
à la poubelle je l'ai récupéré et puis
le la bibliothèque et puis voilà donc on
ne gaspie rien quand je dis par exemple
dans ma famille oh on me dit tiens tu as
une nouvelle robe oui elle m'a coûté une
grenouille le concept séduit de plus en
plus par ces temps de crise les
evvelines comptent actuellement ne
celles